[Music]
hi thanks for sharing your your lunch
time with me I'm going to tell you about
this cool stuff that we're working on
after I tell you why so some potential
customers have shared with us that there
are some barriers for them moving their
workloads to a cloud instead of on-prem
and the biggest three factors are
regulation trust in companies and
compromise and what can happen to the
data that is on other people's machines
right I'm not going to talk too much
about regulation here we go that's the
other button I will tell you how we we
aim to solve problems with trust and
compromise with our open source
framework alright so by trust I mean you
are running your software on other
people's machines and they can be
running arbitrary software to manage
this machines and they can unfortunately
sometimes get compromised not saying
that happens at Google now beyond just
the companies there can be individual
administrators who have access to these
computers so that they can do their jobs
and they can be compromised in one way
to the other through phishing or their
overtly malicious now the compromised
component is when you're running on
these computers they can be subject to
problems in like the Linux kernel
everybody running running on Linux is
open to these same problems there is
also being able to break out of the dma
jail from rogue peripherals and to just
go grab go snooping memory and that's
not so great
so when data is accessible on a machine
and is also subject to legal discovery
so
we consider that also as part of
compromised vectors for confidential
data so enclaves are two things in the
abstract there are isolation for your
execution and data and they are at a
station I wanted to tell you a little
bit about what that means
so isolation is that the operating
system the BIOS Hardware other than the
CPU is all outside of your trust
boundary it is not able to see any of
your memory or tamper with your
execution at all and a typical process
the OS has full control over your app
your process the BIOS can be tampered
with the hardware can have access beyond
what you want right and when this data
is not even available to the kernel and
is only available to your Enclave it is
not subject to legal discovery the
second component of an Enclave is at a
station and attestation aims to answer
the question with cryptographic
guarantees that the software you're
talking to is really the software that
you want to be talking to and that it is
running on the hardware that you expect
to be giving you these trusted execution
environment guarantees when you put
these two things together you're able to
make the following statement that you
can only that you send secrets only to
your software and only your software can
read them and that's really important to
a lot of potential customers who want to
move to cloud for a lot of reasons okay
so
isolation attestation are nice
properties to say that non clave is in
the abstract but unfortunately that is
not an industry standard and there are a
lot of technologies that market
themselves as on clays or trusted
execution environments that don't give
all aspects of isolation at a station
that we really want and because it's too
early to know which one of these
technologies is really going to win in
the marketplace it's nice to have your
Enclave applications be written for an
abstract notion of an enclave so that
you can move around and that's what a
salut is right it is a framework that
abstracts over Enclave technology and
notions of attestation so that you can
easily migrate between different trusted
execution backends and now a really
really awesome cool thing that is in
Oslo is support for POSIX based
application a POSIX based programming
know when you're in one of these trusted
execution environments you have that the
OS is outside of your trusted computing
base which means that you don't get to
use it which means it's really hard to
write software and the typical way that
people usually write software and now to
talk a bit more about how the POSIX
system works in Oslo I want to introduce
my colleague Tom hi I'm gonna briefly
talk about the plastic support that
asilo provides so as the owner talked
earlier in when you saw a long wave it
provides security isolation even from
the operating system so we're having
trouble for code run inside Enclave to
access the resources that's usually
provided by the operating system so solo
provides a POSIX layer to make user
codes
can access to them the way so it which
includes hardware access like clock IO
like readwrite and other kinds of Cisco
Cisco that you normally want to access
we implement them with security features
added so normally when application makes
a Cisco it access the operating system
for the operation but in Enclave case
code running inside Enclave is isolated
from operating system so that's not the
option and we provide Scylla provides a
POSIX layer which is an API level of
implementation for the Cisco's so the
user code that's running inside an
enclave does not need to know okay this
code is running inside Enclave I need to
access the axillary POSIX API they can
just access exactly the Cisco as usual
and a solo POSIX layer will run that
Cisco and in in some cases it they'll
take it exit the Enclave and delegate
the Cisco to the operating system with
security features added to go for a
syllabus Eclair is to provide exactly
the same a behavior as if it's on the
host the user the user code that's need
not need to know it's running inside a
Enclave they can call exactly the same
Cisco as they would on a host and this
week thread you expect exactly the same
behavior the way we do that is for
example for non-sensitive operations
it may just exit the Enclave and
delicate the call to the host and there
are some other interesting examples that
we provide to achieve this goal for
example signals when somebody registers
a handler inside an enclave the estilo
plastics layer saves that handler in
study Enclave then it exits the unpaved
register a handler on the host when the
signal arrives the handler on a host is
invoked which invokes an entry point to
enter the Enclave and invoke the
corresponding handler that's registering
sorry on clave so the user can expect
the same behavior they register a
handler instead on clay
and when the signal arrives their
handler should be vote another
interesting example is forc 40s that's
it's called that Linux uses to create a
process that's exactly same as a parent
however employees are not vulnerable for
security reason so in order to support
that we provide duplication and ink
encryption of the Enclave states so we
load a new Enclave we encrypt the old
Enclave data and we store that in the
new Enclave
thus the security features for folk is
not fully implemented yet we're working
actively to support secure fork and even
though we are providing security
features for the Cisco's that we provide
sometimes it's not impossible to make it
fully secure our website a Scylla data
we have documentation fully detailed of
Cisco that we provide and if there is
any the possible security concern or
issues it may have the user code should
investigate into that when before they
make it Cisco's and so what we have
support right now for a Scylla POSIX
layer is we have provide enough forces
POSIX layer support to run a
fully-featured G RPC we can also run a
few feature latest open source Redis I
would do a quick demo later to show how
we can do that and in both cases we
don't need to make any source change to
either of them we can just pull exactly
the same code from the github and run
that inside and Enclave with the solo so
welcome to check check out our website a
solo debut if you're interested for
updates and documentation for a solo and
our open source project is at github.com
/ Google slash your solo you can check
it out if interested in and I'm going to
do a quick demo to show how you can run
Redis inside an enclave
so what do you need to run a user
application like Redis inside an enclave
is a workspace so first you need a
workspace file sorry the color is
probably a little bit hard to read bad
so right here you want to import it's
somehow it's not showing the whole thing
but you want to import a civil right
here a little point three point four is
the latest release that we have and of
course you want to import Redis if
that's the user application you want to
build the latest open source which
already is five point zero point four
asila provides a beautiful in a civil
code base that's buttes Redis with basil
which is the Google beauty tool and
other than that you need a dot basil RC
file this basically tells basil what to
chain what costo to use and what the
beautiful fakes are this is the exactly
same file copied from a solo github we
don't need to make any changes finally
the own the last thing you need is the
beaut argot to tell basil what do you
want to build so here we provide an
application wrapper which wraps the user
main function entrance in the trusted
part of the code the wrong method so the
only thing we need is to wrap that in CC
Enclave binary which is our application
wrapper you give it a name and you put
what you want to build as a few target
in the dependencies so here Redis main
is the target that runs the ready server
so that's everything you need now we can
just build the beauty application
wrapper so basil beauty azo is the
Google beaut tool so we give it a config
which is awesome cause it to view the
targets in a simulated environment
and a silhouette is is the target that
we just had for Cece Enclave binary here
it is you can see that it be it's very
quickly it speakers I have previewed it
because we don't have enough time to
build it right here okay so once you
have that beaut we are ready to run the
binary which is placed in the Faisal bin
and this is the binary we just viewed
and we run a binary we can see that
reddit server is running it's up it's
running inside Enclave here we have a
warning about current maximum open file
is a thousand 24 that's because this is
the current maximum file descriptors we
allow with a solo inside an enclave and
so now it's ready to accept connections
so in a different terminal we run Redis
client to connect to the server we can
pin it and we can set whatever key and
the value and get it just like normally
you would use Redis okay that's
everything I have for the demo is there
any questions thank you John thank you
[Music]